- De Old Orchard à Ogunquit,
les plages du Maine
représentent, pour bien
des Québécois, un endroit
de vacances accessible
et appréciée.
Il a fallu s'en passer pendant
deux ans en raison de la COVID,
mais l'attente est terminée
et ils sont déjà nombreux
à être de retour.
- Depuis mon enfance.
- Depuis votre enfance?
- C'est comme un rituel,
à chaque année.
- Le petit pélérinage à Ogunquit
qui souligne le début de l'été.
- L'eau est comment?
- Elle est glaciale!
(rires)
- Pour le moment.
Charlotte et Pierre Roger ne
sont pas des grands baigneurs.
Que l'eau soit seulement
à 15 degrés ne les dérange pas.
- On a réservé en novembre
l'année passée. Qu a a a a vu
que les douanes rouvraient,
on a dit : On réserve et
si ça marche pas, on annulera!
- Du pur bonheur de retrouver...
bien, ce qu'on attendait :
la détente, le bruit des vagues
quand on se couche le soir,
la... juste la vue.
- À voir les plaques "Je me
souviens" dans le stationnement
du motel qu'ils ont réservé,
ils ne sont pas les seuls
qui t t t t pressés de retrouver
Old Orchard Beach. Leur motel
s'appelle d'ailleurs le Kebec 3.
- Hi, how are you?
- Selon sa gérante, 80% des
clients y sont Québécois.
À Old Orchard, les Québécoisfoe
de la communauté depuis
des décennies.
- Beaucoup, beaucoup
de souvevevevevec les enfants,
et même les petits enfants,
et des souvenirs de jeunesse.
Même de jeunesse, oui!'o'o'o'on!
(rires)
- Ces 2 dernières années,
le Maine a accueilli beaucoup
de nouveaux touristes américains
qui découvraient leur pays
faute de pouvoir aller ailleurs.
Mais l'absence des Québécois
s'est quand même fait sentir.
Selon l'Office du Tourisme
aiaiaiaine, avant la pandémie
en 2019, 2,300 millions
Canadiens sont venus visiter
le Maine et ont dépensé ici
1,3 milliard de dollars.
Bien sûr, pendant la pandém
ces chiffres ont dégringolé. Et,
l'an dernier, seulement 63 000
visiteurs sont venus du Canada
et ont dépensé 40 fois moins;
32 millions de dollars.
Ce camping de Wells est resté
fermé deux ans. Jennifer
Batchhelder et son conjoint
l'ont rouvert en mai et ont vite
su que l'été serait très occupé.
On a aussi rencontré
Ramsay Lafayette, qui gère
trois hôtels en bord de mer.
Son conseil : réservez
vos nuits rapidement
pour un séjour cet été.
- There's such an increase...
- La demande est grande
et les prix ont explos
un peu partout dans le Maine.
Même dans les motels dits
abordables, une famille
de quatre qui souhaite passer
la fin de semaine du 16 juillet
à Ogunquit, par exemple,
paiera minimum 3nt taxes
chaque nuit.
L'inflation vient d'atteindre
8,6 % aux États-Unis, un record
en 40 ans.
Le prix de l'essence a beau
avoir atteint un record lui
aussi aux États-Unis, il coûte
seulement 1,35 $ Canadien
le litre, ce qui compense un peu
pour le prix de la nourriture,
qui est en très forte hausse.
Plus que jamais, le homard
devient un luxe.
- Le lobster roll coûtait
environ 20 $. Maintenant,
il est à 26 $!
- C'esUSUSUSUS la livre. Oui!
C'est une augmentation aussi.
- Mais malgré les prix,
ils semblaient tous heureux.
Les Québécois sont de retour
sur leur bord de mer et
c'est ce qui compte le plus.
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, Ogunqui